anyone gearing up to buying the latest
iPhone 14 pro or iPhone Pro Max for
Christmas better stop and take a deep
breath because Apple has warned to
expect longer wait times to receive its
latest products ahead of the holiday
season because of China's strict zero
covet policy the tech giant has
announced that its production facility
in zhangjo the world's largest iPhone
Factory has been locked down Apple said
the assembly plant operated by Foxconn
is producing at significantly reduced
capacity adding to the Grim picture
China's export slumped 0.3 percent in
October their sharpest decline since May
2020.
all right for more on this let's bring
in Tech analyst Ivan lamb in Hong Kong
and correspondent Fabian kretchmer in
Beijing Fabian let me start with you
what can you tell us about the
conditions and the situation at the uh
Foxconn planned in jeongzhou
the plant is also called iPhone City
because it produces roughly 80 of the
newest uh iPhone generation and it's
also as big as a city I mean with uh up
to 300 000 workers there and when
Zhengzhou basically went into lockdown
the authorities implemented a closed
loop Management on the production side
closed loop that means that the workers
basically can only move from their
dormitory to the work side so it's a
really harsh conditions and on social
media we've seen a lot of posts um
stating by workers that you know the
medical conditions are not sufficient
some were even fearing like not enough
food supply so what happened is that um
several thousands workers they were
fleeing they left the production side
because they didn't want to work there
anymore also out of panic that um the
virus might spread within this closed
loop management and Foxconn so far has
even offered a recruitment bonus for any
worker that would return
Ivan over to you in Hong Kong demand for
high-end smartphones has helped Apple
remain a bright spot in an otherwise
battered technology sector what does
this reduction in output now mean for
Apple
so foreign
news to them will be like reduce their
output and and then uh as Apple said
they already extend uh lower the
expectation from the consumer and then
the output may be extended for some
dealers and some own channel
achievements but this output uh still uh
uh on only for the iPhone 14 pro and pro
Max but for the 14 and 14 plus it's not
effect too much
Ivan is this uh then the situation that
apple is experiencing now is this a boon
for Apple's competitors
uh to me I think to uh for the
Commodities it's not actually a a boom
because currently the overall all uh
smartphone oems are facing the same
situation that the macro have things and
also the team demand from the consumer
side so Apple still can maintain their
position on the high end
uh Fabian back to you in in Beijing um
Chinese experts are down for the first
time since
mid-2020 what are the prospects of the
zero covet strategy that Beijing has
been pursuing that strategy being eased
yeah that's a good question I mean the
trade numbers are really disappointing
and they are approved to what degree
zero covet is hurting the economy
however on Saturday the National Health
commission gave a press conference
clearly stating that the country will
stick to zero covet
um but let me tell you the numbers are I
mean the infection numbers are as high
as you know early may I mean the biggest
uh rise in affections since uh basically
half a year so it's entirely possible
that the virus at some point will force
in opening up there's really a critical
timing we can see that also in Beijing
more and more residential compounds are
put under lockdown and um really it is
questionable if China can again contain
the spread of the virus or not them
correspondent Fabian kretchmer in
Beijing and Tech analyst even Ivan lamb
in Hong Kong thank you to you both